foreign
what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg here joined by John how are you I'm
I'm in a days we just got out of watching black
panther wakanda forever leave a like don't forget
to do that now we're shooting this in Burbank we
got our friend Aaron holding the camera burbank's
really serious about [__] around here at any
moment we could be tackled by security I know
what are you doing here stop filming pay us for
this time now in case you don't know anything
about this film there's gonna be no spoilers
here and this movie takes place after the
passive t'challa Chadwick Boseman as you see in
the trailers there's people who are seeing this
as a moment of vulnerability for wakanda they're
trying to take vibranium this movie's two hours
and 40 something minutes there's a lot of plot
even involving why Neymar and them are fighting
that is just not revealed in the trailers I know
some people don't care if they talk about it but
because the marketing he didn't put it out there
I don't want to put it out there but know this
the movie's like a really long film and I thought
every second every minute of it was so Justified I
loved this movie so much when I saw the trailers I
kept saying it feels like it's going to be so much
about grief and having to work together through
grief simultaneously be badass I found myself
like crying for a variety of different reasons
from beginning to end feeling hopeful feeling
just so shattered my brain feels foggy from all
the crying at this very moment it is the most
powerful MCU movie I have seen the easily the most
emotional it felt like such a necessary experience
for everyone involved with this movie feels
so purposeful it's like an epic drama is how I
would describe it you know before we go into like
Namor Sheree Angela Bassett my God ramonda yeah
John what'd you think no I I'm similarly dazed
because it is such a cathartic experience and
because it does intermingle so much with
actual life yeah there are crazy high
concept things happening on screen and yet it
still feels completely personal the entire time
and every action feels motivated by the grief and
vulnerability that everybody on screen is feeling
for different reasons and you know coming out
of the previous movie it still maintains all of
that geopolitical Intrigue because obviously
in the place we rejoin wakanda they are in a
globally vulnerable state not just an emotionally
vulnerable state but you get this interesting
mixture where so much of the action literally even
the fighting that happens on screen does feel like
it is coming from the same place as a lot of the
dramatic scenes it is you know the most powerful
and the most meaningful and the most impactful MCU
movie probably in rousing as hell it is yeah yeah
yeah but not in the way of like how an end game is
rousing yeah it's not on your left yeah but it is
like it has a life of firming quality just as much
as it is about grieving the loss of somebody and
there are some really beautiful cultural motifs
that they use to drive that home that really sing
beyond all the other stuff that you're expecting
that is there too like it's still thrilling and
it's still fun and it's still endearing in ways
but yeah there is a Paul that they don't turn
away from that is cast over the entire proceedings
and even characters who aren't going through what
the wakandans are going through have similarly
vital motivations and griefs of their own to
rectify between everyone in wakanda to everyone
in telecon and in between there's so much life
and culture and Beauty on display that it's weird
so many people I think would want to imagine this
movie any other way if it meant Chadwick could
be here and I certainly would probably trade
for that reality but at the same time the on the
timeline we live on this does feel like a unique
snapshot of a moment that also gets to be all
the MCU stuff you want it to be too and I think
that's really special there are some really just
powerful performances in here it's the the best
I think out of the Marvel Cinematic Universe I'll
be honest like I was well I was looking forward to
shuri but I wasn't exactly walking into this film
going can't wait to see what Leticia Wright does
for some reason I just wasn't in that mindset
what I noticed was that there are times where
when she had scenes where she was like displaying
Joy or happiness I would start to tear up or cry
because her portrayal here carries this this ever
growing pain throughout the entire film that's
coming out in all kinds of ways of aggression
and anger and drive it would just break my heart
whenever I would see her happy you know it's it's
that kind of it's just it's getting me right now
it would just mess me up because you could see how
palpable and how much it just resonates throughout
the entire film because that's what this film's so
much about is everyone's struggling emotional only
right now and we're just trying to keep moving
and everyone's threatening us and the only way
we can stay together through such a tumultuous
time is by Banning together so that phrase like
calling this wakanda forever I felt that way
more than the first black panther way more than
whatever it's been said I felt that like yeah
wakanda forever you just feel that phrase that
Mantra but it's such a personal fill like it's
so personal it's two hours and 40 minutes for
a reason it is a slow-moving film that will have
action scenes that are just so intense like this
is Cinema all right this is James Cameron Cameron
this is a great film there are these action scenes
in here where the intensity it's suspenseful
it's engaging and you're watching characters
even on the side of Neymar they're not Atlantis
yeah they call them a different thing I forget
how you adapt telecon into its people's name but
yeah even with them it's everyone's just trying
to do their best and they they have these core
themes about family and about vengeance and about
how to cope and it's just like that in this giant
massive expensive ass film at the same time Namor
he was so threatening and he's easily one of
the best Marvel villains I was halfway through
watching him monologue at one scene and then I got
pulled out for a split second going holy [__]
this guy's incredible I know because I haven't
even thought about like how great he's doing
because he's so he just feels like this character
yeah he's just he just is this person you get
entirely where he's coming from the flying the
action scenes with him are awesome and as much
as you get where he's coming from he also pisses
you off so much at times yeah it's a really great
dichotomy they draw because he is completely
understandable and yet he is your antagonist for
various reasons and it's really effectively done
it does not succumb to these stereotype of like
oh you're just kind of going up against yourself
like it definitely avoids that and it gives you
somebody with a clear motive a clear purpose that
you can again continuing that line from what we
got with killmonger it's like you you understand
where this guy's coming from but more so even than
killmonger I would argue Angela Bassett I believe
deserves an Oscar nomination for this I don't
think I've said that about an MCU performance the
strength and Poise and the amount of command she
has on the screen green you've seen Angela Bassett
do an intense performance but there is so much
more percolating underneath it yeah like I would
absolutely agree I'm like please nominate her like
I notice you keep saying pain doesn't sound like a
fun movie but it's like a necessary pain it's like
you're grieving through with these characters
you're doing all this necessary World building
and you're exploring talocon like there's so much
I'm like wow the trailers didn't show you so much
there's so much Beauty on display deny Guerrera
as a koye just you know like man you miss you
missed the Charlie you missed Chadwick with Ryan
coogler and company gave with their performers
here this is the performance of them that I'm
going to remember every one of them first black
panther I'm like I really like them but of course
Chadwick and Michael B Jordan those are the ones
you think of it's a true Ensemble peace masterful
performances and yeah it is I'm sorry for talking
so much and Baku Winston Duke total blast to kick
it with seen stealer Riri Williams was the quality
of this film I was concerned about this film
obviously is looked at as something so personal I
felt are we gonna get distracted by them trying to
set up Iron Man she's a very important character
in this film and she fits yeah perfectly yeah
it is not just hey look how far ironhearted
it is not that she felt like such a real person
this friendship that she forms with shuri by the
time you know the movie was ending I was like
oh no I want to still see them hang out I don't
wanna I wanna still see them together and it makes
you hope that shuri will appear somewhere in Iron
Heart to just continue that Rapport they have
everything to me comes back to Leticia Wright
for this film whatever personal opinions you
have about Leticia right everything comes back
to me about like it circles around her she was
perfect absolutely mesmerizing oh my God yes no
yeah like revelatory and and the way especially
she is used in the movie without saying much is
interesting and does come with very much catharsis
and a lot of its own tough emotion that is unique
it's like you have everyone sharing you know
a certain amount of grief obviously but I feel
like at the center of the story you have shuri
but you also have Nakia in a way that you know
isn't really a part of what people are talking
about or what's being pitched to you but she is
one of the brightest parts of the movie I feel
like when you see the trailer you know what
you're hearing a lot about is they've lost their
leader and now it falls on the remaining people
in wakanda to carry on the Legacy and to take
a stand and and show their strengths still so
what they did with this film was they went okay
let's not try to find a new lead let's instead
really hone in on our supporting players from the
last movie and make them the leads as tragic as it
is as beautiful as a tribute as this film is like
you feel Chadwick boseman's missing presence and
presence throughout you feel his spirit imbued in
everything like when you say the missing presence
it's not like the movie's not good because this
would have been good yeah that's something we're
saying you feel the longing that weight of the
loss of someone but weirdly I felt like they
came out with a film that was better than the
first one personally for me I feel like this
is a better film The action's really great and
imaginative and dazzling yeah this is like the
wakanda version of the winter soldier action in
some ways you know a little bit of that Aquaman
wonder I think they made the underwater stuff
look better than Aquaman it felt real more real
versus not trying to make this like a Marvel
vs DC comparison it just felt actually real
the music by all oh this is some of the absolute
this is absolutely a cinematic score yeah it feels
spiritual throughout and it takes those motifs
from the previous movie but it builds on them
in really wonderful ways it uses vocalizations
and two it crosses cultural boundaries because
you are dealing with ancient uh I think they they
name check my commands yeah it's like you know you
have so much hang in there beyond the the music
of wakanda that just makes it feel so much more
rich and alive and all the flourishes like you can
really feel the elegant quality of the tones that
they pull the sound design is amazing the makeup
and effects are awesome my only real problem with
the film is that at times and it's not like oh
Marvel phase four it all the just the crap you
crap on with the marble face force CGI it is like
there are times in the especially in the finale
where you're like you had some very noticeable CGI
but when I was thinking that I was going Owen what
movie doesn't with a hat that relies on CGI some
shots will inevitably be a bit better than others
nobody has all the time they need it even the
greatest technological looking movie of at the
time it comes out you will have moments that go
man that looks fake like some other minor qualms
I might have with the movie because yeah I do
think it does a fantastic job World building and
handling this Ensemble because it is very well
written the entire thing is motivated within
characters it's a big film but it's also extremely
character driven but at times the editing can feel
a tad off Pace but out of two hours and 40 minutes
that thought maybe crossed my mind at a very small
handful of times and there there's the humor works
and there's only one scene of humor that felt like
typical quote-unquote Marvel comedy but the rest
of the scenes that make you laugh they don't feel
that way I thought this was a damn near perfect
experience and exactly what I thought it should
be more than what I wanted it to be or expected
it to be I thought it was great there's a heavy
hole throughout but also inspiring and hopeful did
you just take different directions with characters
you just wouldn't expect and yes perhaps the
best post-credits scene because it's a legit
powerful scene and not just like hey what's coming
next yeah yeah it's it's very very spiritually
in line with the movie it makes sense to separate
it and make it the coda and I think it's a really
elegant use yeah it feels like the real ending
yeah yeah absolutely I think it was a really
elegant choice to do it that way like it could
have ended where it ended but the post-credit
feels like no this is the real ending and it does
seem like the kind of movie that will give you
more on repeat viewings for sure I want to watch
it a couple more times but could be my favorite
of the it's just above throw 11th it could be my
favorite uh I I don't know yet I have to watch it
again what'd you guys think subscribe leave a like
click that Bell um yeah wakanda forever this was
this is one experience I'm never gonna forget no
never never it was awesome this is truly unique